rescued during a dangerous journey
across the mediterranean to europe
in less than 24 hours more than 400
migrants were picked up by humanitarian
group sea watch
it's a risk many of them know all too
well
many of them know that it's quite likely
that they won't make it that they
potentially will drown in in trying to
seek safety
but for them
it's the only option they have and these
are the stories that we hear and these
are people that we meet time and time
again
nearby other groups of migrants and
refugees wait on the island of lampedusa
more than a thousand arrived in italy
within hours many are from afghanistan
pakistan sudan ethiopia and somalia
basically european states are dedicating
all of their efforts in stopping people
from making their way to european shores
so it's a policy of exclusion and
isolation
the island's reception center has a
capacity for 300 people but three times
as many migrants are there
the influx comes as italy gears up for
early elections which could bring
hard-right politicians to power
the united nations says more than 30
thousand migrants and refugees have
arrived in italy by sea this year
and more than 1200 have reportedly died
attempting to reach europe
katya lopez
al jazeera